welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and the ending of
you season 2 really has the Internet and
a frenzy right now the final few scenes
of the show introduce a brand new
character and throughout this video
we'll be breaking down the best fan
theories about who this could be and all
of the evidence to support it there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the finale yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of who
Joe's new neighbor is think we have some
unfinished business to talk about
[Music]
but it's a new me okay so you season two
so Joe moved to LA and change his name
to will Joe became besotted with a local
chef named love who he began stalking
manipulating and similar to back in
season one the two slowly formed an
attachment love was head over heels with
the character and we later learned that
she had a dark side to her to when she
committed several murders in order to
protect him
this not only included Joe's neighbor
Delilah but also his ex-girlfriend
Candice who had followed the character
to LA in order to expose him and ruin
his life
geo wanted to get away from her but once
she dropped the bombshell that she was
pregnant he quickly abandon all plans of
escape and decided to settle down with
the character love's brother forty
uncovered the truth and justice he was
about to murder Joe he was shot by a
police officer
allowing Joe and love to move away to
the LA suburbs and raise their child
together Joe finally had it all a woman
that he loved a successful Netflix TV
show a future family and he'd managed to
get away with everything
meaning that he could now live a
comfortable life however as with most
stalkers Psychopaths and serial killers
that driven purely by compulsion and we
ended the season with Joe looking
through a crack in his fence and coming
across a new fixation it was one of the
biggest twists in the entire season and
it reminded us that no matter what
happens
geo will always be this manipulative
self-centered stalker that enjoys
controlling women we heard the character
going through the usual narration in his
head you know you know the one that kick
starts the season and we knew that he
was once more in a prison I was own
making Joe said this is just the
beginning because this is where I had to
be I'll stop doing the voice because
this is where I had to be exactly where
I had to be to meet you
there you were with your books in your
sunshine so close but worlds away I will
figure out a way a way to get to you see
you soon
neighbor eagle-eyed viewers also spotted
that throughout the season there were
actually several clues that Joe would
end up fixated on another person with
YouTube user a Theo ke saying on my last
video the main character name is Joe and
he's pretending to be will his
love interest is love and the title of
the show is you so piece it all together
Joe will love you this makes me think
that perhaps the entire show has sort of
been like How I Met Your Mother
situation where we are merely watching
the events play out until he meets you
not you like like the character in the
show that the entire seasons named after
you as in her anyway I promise it's not
you either you don't have to delete
Instagram just yet we can't see the
woman's face but she can be seen reading
a stack of books and like Joe everyone
has been obsessing over who this could
be now one of the big fan theories that
is flowing about at the moment is that
this is back the ending of season 1 left
her death completely ambiguous and know
Joe was haunted by visions of the
character throughout season 2 we do know
that he's an unreliable narrator and
therefore he's very difficult to trust
Joe plays things differently in his head
to how they actually are and he often
recontextualizes scenarios in order to
make it appear like he's the good guy
Joe made a killing of Beck's book
literally and she will also likely want
to track down the character if he's
still out there she was an avid book fan
and would definitely have motive to go
after him but how was she even able to
track him down well you may have noticed
since season 2 that Joe's laptop was in
fact pecks old one and if the character
has an app installed in order to track
its location then this could lead her
directly to Joe where this theory falls
apart though is that Penn Badgley has
flat out said that Beck is dead
and though I would like to see a return
this seems highly unlikely the next
theory is actually one that I haven't
seen many people talking about and that
is that the character is dr. Nikki's
wife dr. Nikki made a big appearance in
the finale of season 2 and stated that
he didn't want to reopen any old wounds
when it comes to Joe so 40 was enabled
to gather any evidence against him the
character did mention that Jude who is
cheating he ruined his marriage and it
is possible at Nikki's wife angered that
Joe destroyed their relationship has
decided to track the character down make
him infatuated with her and then frame
him for a murder so that he becomes
locked up after escaping the long arm of
the law
twice she could also be involved with
Peach's parents who are still
investigating the death of their
daughter
and as that jar of pee from when gel
broke into a house was never resolved
they could be secretly building their
own case against him again this theory
it doesn't have all that much way to it
but it's possible especially because the
fact that many characters from season
one are aware that something was up with
the character and they want to track him
down finally though there's a big fan
theory that is taking the internet by
storm and that is that the neighbor is
Joe's mother throughout season two we
learned the ins and outs of Joe's
childhood as well as what caused him to
develop a severe personality disorder
I'm sorry Joe I shouldn't have said that
you you're a great guy and only anyone
would be lucky to have you anyway at the
center of it all was Joe's relationship
with his mother the woman who pretty
much started him down the life of
stalking and manipulation that led him
to where we saw him at the end of season
two could it be that Joe is actually now
obsessing over his mother well
potentially the real will and Joe do
have a discussion early on in the season
that men are just trying to marry their
own mothers and initially when I heard
this conversation I was a bit taken
aback but looking at its inclusion in
the context of the finale it does make a
lot of sense in several flashbacks we
saw Joe end up killing one of his
mother's boyfriends after he repeatedly
beat her Joe grew up in the foster
system and it is possible that the
entire journey that the character has
been on has been a date with destiny
with his own mother
yikes his mother constantly promised to
save Joe from the violent situations
that he was subjected to but he ended up
having to take control of the situation
himself
could he have stalked her finally
catching up with her and moving in next
door in order to show her that he could
actually make a family well yeah I think
he could have actually he is a bit crazy
we don't know the real motives behind
this but if it turns out to be true it
could be a massively interesting premise
for season 3 we can tell from the
woman's hands that this is an older lady
and she does look roughly about the age
that Joe's mother would now be during
the season there's a conversation
between love and Joe in which they talk
about whether his mother is alive or
dead and the latter doesn't really
confirm it leaving it ambiguous if she
was dead though I do think that Joe
would use this as a way to get
from love so we can lean more towards
the fact that she's alive and he just
hasn't mentioned her because it would
cause complications there's definitely
potential here and it would be a massive
massive twist if this turned out to be
true
the final theory is that the character
is someone that we've never actually
seen before and they've been introduced
to the finale to show the struggle that
Joe goes through internally and that
he'll never actually have a happy life
because the grass will always be greener
this could definitely be the case and if
there isn't a third season then at least
we would end up with somewhat a sense of
closure knowing that Joe will forever be
destined to ruin his relationships there
hasn't been a third book written yet but
it is in production so it is very likely
that we will see what happens with the
neighbor either way though I doubt that
love will be very happy with Joe now
having someone else that he's in love
with and we all know that she's capable
of murder with her now having a baby and
the family she's always been desperate
for for so long it is likely that she'll
do whatever she can to keep a hold of it
so I doubt you'd be playing by the rules
it's all fair in love and war and who
knows if the most popular theory turns
out to be true then the next season
could end up being about between Joe's
wife and his mother over who the
character wants to spend the rest of his
life with there's a lot of potential
here and I can't wait to see what
happens next time now obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on these theories
and which one you're siding with comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the season which you'll be
linked at the end we discuss everything
that you need to know about the show and
give our thoughts on it as a whole so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of Joker which
is one of our favorite movies of the air
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is like the video like
she subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on you in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of January
and the set will be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize the best of
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]